are you ready to give it a try what are
the set of media queries you need to
apply in order to apply styles from
these classes use this diagram as a
guide class AAA applies from 0 to 400
pixels class BB applies from 300 in 1
pixels to 600 CC applies for any browser
with the width greater than 601 pixels
and DD applies for any browser with the
width greater than 961 pixels you'll
need to write for media queries one for
Class A a one for class BB CC and DD in
order for a class to display set it to
display block and when you type out your
answers don't worry about new lines just
make your media queries one long line so
they fit in the box I'll go ahead and
start you off with at media for each of
the media queries and then at the end of
it I went ahead and drew these curly
braces if these were real media queries
this is where the styles would go finish
them up in good luck